hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his short work the stoic paradoxes
where Cicero is presenting some of the
key ideas of stoic ethics that many
people find quite difficult to grasp or
to accept Cicero makes a very important
distinction that runs throughout the
entire work between what is genuinely
good and what people might call good but
isn't really good it's not necessarily
bad by not being good but it but it just
doesn't have moral value the way that
people often think that it does here he
is following the Stoics but this is also
his own view on things and he says that
we can find illustrations of this in the
lives of famous Romans we might think of
other people in our own culture who
similarly exhibit these sort of forms of
goodness in concrete ways so let's start
off by talking about what he says is
genuinely good and notice that there's
going to be sort of a restriction many
of the things that we talk about is good
or indeed other philosophers have talked
about as good are not going to be
considered good in this way so he says
what is genuinely good and this is a
little bit of summary here it has three
different qualities to it or it can be
described in in three ways and these
intersect and overlap with each other to
some degree what is right what is
upright is another way of translating it
rectum what is honorable or noble a
little bit difficult to translate this
whole nessam the word that we get honest
from you might think of it as that which
is intrinsically valuable or that which
has its own goodness by its very nature
and then he brings up this other term
with virtue converter to thing which of
course could include virtue itself as
something that is good amma Stoics
thought that you know what is
fundamentally good has to do with the
you might say interior of the person and
the choices and the actions that they in
ajun so I think it's fairly easy to wrap
our heads around the comb vitter to tape
art you know with virtue
the Stoics recognized four main virtues
very similar to what the plate inist had
that is prudence justice temperance and
courage these are good states of
character that have been established in
a person that are displayed through
behavior consistently that you know are
durable they can be expected to go from
situation to situation and then the
actions that come out of that actions
that are guided by prudence that are
expressive of virtue that have their
route encouraged and and so on when it
comes to what is right and what is
honorable or noble I think it's very
often useful to look at examples that
Cicero will we'll use some of these are
examples of people showing the virtues
like courage she talks about a lot of
people in Roman history displaying
courage in their battles you know quite
desperate battles of Rome with its
enemies but also thriftiness and you
know moderation or temperance or justice
all of those those sorts of things and
in given situations the Stoics think
that we can in fact determine what would
be the right thing we're not going to
worry about you know what the exact way
of figuring that out would be and that
there are some things that are elevated
above others that we ought to prefer and
sacrifice for if need be the honorable
or Noble now what are not actually good
according to the Stoics this is where
people are more likely to diverge from
it so money for example money is not a
good it's not a bad thing as a matter of
fact the Stoics would talk about this in
a very technical way as they preferred
indifferent we're not going to worry
about that at this point but it is
something that it's okay to have houses
he talks about and we might think of you
know whatever domiciles furnishings that
you have for your house as he talks
about Corinthian vases
an example of the things that the Romans
had brought back with them as spoils for
war power offices positions certain
types of Honor we might think of in this
way not the Honorable as such but the
kind of honor that people give like
celebrity right having lots of likes on
your videos or your page or your Twitter
you know feed or whatever and many talks
later on about another thing that makes
its claim on us because some people say
yeah those those those things that you
can you know have or have taken away
from you that you can take away from
somebody else not really good but what
really is good is pleasure pleasure is
something that is more distinctively
your own and Cicero will say no that's
not a good either
the Stoics but that pleasure itself was
not a good in this they were going
against the grain not only of the
Epicureans who are another major
philosophical school at the time and the
common culture but also the Aristotelian
and some of the other schools of
philosophy now it gets very interesting
when we look at his his crew the answers
to the question why why aren't these
things good as opposed to this so Cicero
tells us that what is good should not in
some way turn out to be bad for the
person but we can think of you know all
sorts of cases where money didn't
actually make somebody's life or
situation better but made it worse we
talked about power revealing the bad
character of the person who had it and
then displayed what their character was
but wasn't able to do that before they
had power we talked about you know
houses and furnishings as soon as you
get yourself you know a fancy house now
you have to start paying taxes on it
people might rob you all these these
sorts of things so if you if you use
these sorts of things as a criteria then
it turns against itself by their own
criteria bad things often do happen to
people
wind up with with good in the apparent
sense good things pacing with pleasures
pleasure can actually make things worse
in many respects you can think of all
sorts of examples of pleasures we
indulge in and then afterwards say oh I
should not have done that now here is
where we get to another criterion it's
very interesting
Cicero says Goods should make a person
good this is an argument that goes all
the way back to Plato and it's reflected
in our own time he actually talks about
you know do we say that a person who's
enjoying pleasure it becomes a better
person because of that or that a person
who has money by having the money
becomes better well we do in our common
culture we act as if that's the case
same thing with power of course but does
it really make the person better it
doesn't have to make them worse to not
make them better and these things don't
make a person could this does in fact
make a person a better person acquiring
the virtues recognizing some higher
standard that you have to live up to
will indeed make you a better person and
when that good becomes your own when you
become virtuous you thereby become a
better person another key thing is that
Goods should make their possessors happy
and we can ask ourselves do these other
things actually make us happy leave
pleasure aside for a moment because
there is an argument that could be made
there what about money houses
furnishings power all of these sorts of
things that Cicero says hey I I know
about this because I see my peers
pursuing these things like crazy when
they have them are they really happy or
do they keep on desiring more and more
and more of them do these satisfy that's
a key question Cicero says actually no
what they do is they not only don't
satisfy appetite or desire they arouse
yet more desire or lust
libido
they also arouse fear Mattu in Latin
Mateus
that you might lose those things that
you have so they don't actually make us
happy when it comes to pleasure cicero
also introduces the consideration of
what our rational human nature involves
he says yes you know people do think
that pleasure is a good it is indeed a
good for animals but it's not the
distinctively human good that we should
be pursuing we have minds we have some
sort of intellect we have a higher
nature and he talks about you know this
is this call of pleasure really being
the voice of cattle not of human beings
and so in a way that's similar to this
question of whether we're going to be
happy by possessing that thing that's
presenting itself as a good that is
pleasure or whether we'll be made happy
rather by possessing the the genuine
good the genuine good will realize our
nature as human beings so this is not
simply like rule-following this means
the full development of human capacities
as a rational being so there is the
distinction between genuine goods and
what we might call spurious or only
apparent goods that are called so by the
many
you